Apple released the first version of the
Apple TV back in 2007 the same year
released the first iphone since then the
iphone has changed the world the apple
TV is basically just still a hobby at
Apple until now the new apple TV is
meant to give Apple a better shot at
winning the war for the living room the
new set-top box looks a lot like its
predecessors its boxy black and plugs
into your TV the big difference is that
Apple's voice-activated personal
assistant Siri can now run the device to
show me funny movies from the 1980s you
can talk to it through a newly designed
remote control which contains a touchpad
that lets you swipe through a video
catalog as well as fast forward through
TV shows and movies and a microphone to
let you search your TV with your voice
Apple is opening the set-top box to
developers who can bring games and
shopping apps into your living room the
new Apple TV starts at $149 pricey in a
category where the Roku costs 100 and
the Amazon fire stick sell for only
thirty nine dollars it goes on sale this
October if this version of the apple TV
is going to be a hit it's because
third-party developers will make it one